yeah good morning you know we don't get
to see this every day this morning we're
at community ambulance here a privately
owned ambulance company in henderson and
we're finding out how they're working to
solve the shortages and what they're
doing to bring more workers on the force
this is glenn good morning to you good
morning thanks for having us so tell us
a little bit about you know what you
guys do here yeah so community aims
we're a private locally owned company
here in southern nevada
and we're we're in the midst of hosting
a job fair today so you guys see it
every day you guys are you know on the
front lines what sort of you know this
is an interesting question what's the
personality trait someone would would
need to have to to have this role
yeah so we're
our motto here at community ambulance is
heart and it's in our logo so heart
stands for honesty excellence
accountability respect and teamwork and
that's what we're looking for in
individuals that are interested in this
career gotcha and so just show us a
little bit here you were giving us some
interesting information about this yeah
so we have a lot of incentives one of
our big incentives that we think
is important to the backs and and saving
everybody is our power load system
so our power load system it's a one-man
operation and so it's saving the backs
of our providers when they're going out
there why is this unique for you guys
so we're the only private ambulance
company here in southern nevada that has
this in our entire 9-1-1 fleet
and again it's it's all about taking
care of our employees and so that's what
we're trying to do so as we talk about
these shortages can you just sort of
drive it home why is it so critical to
make sure we have the staffing that we
need
yeah you know obviously the height of
the pandemic we're seeing hospitals some
of their volumes at some all-time highs
and so we're looking to continually
increase that staff and as the city
grows as we bring more events to this
exciting city we want to make sure we
have the staff to to provide the safety
that that's necessary to keep the city
open and going it's also interesting you
mentioned you guys are offering up to a
ten thousand dollar bonus yes that
sounds pretty crazy yeah so you know we
want to take care of our employees and
so our employees are all going to see
upwards of a 14 raise in addition we're
offering sign-on bonuses up to 10
thousand dollars if you join the team
communityambulance.com click on careers
and hopefully you'll come out and see us
awesome thank you so much for your time
um so yeah we'll be uh showing you
another part of the operations here
again we are in henderson we'll have
those details more about those details
on the job fair still ahead in the next
half hour reporting live hector mejia
live local now